[Applaudissements]
tu parles
sinon ouais quelques-uns mais le pire le
pire tu veux dire le moment d'un track
dingue
j'en ai eu beaucoup hein pas notre pas
le trac un moment vraiment l'habitude
lancé sur arte m6 awards 2011 sera sera
pas c'est bien toi
vous n'êtes pas voilà m6 se voit même
s'il décide de faire c'est là une fois
et jamais de 1,54 artistes le zénith de
lille en direct
d'accord cinquante quatre artistes dont
gilo britney spears même mylène farmer
ce qui est assez rare vous imaginez
mollahs pour citer donner un peu
l'ambiance
m6 se remet donc des prix même si ce
world et on est en direct
et là il se trouve que ce zénith de
lille qui est génial dick delbarre
comprennent la première fois au zénith
de lille nous le faisons au zénith de
lille en direct
il se trouve qu'il ya des monte-charges
n'y voyez aucune malveillance de ma part
pour les artistes parce que évidemment
il ya plusieurs niveaux 54 artistes y en
a un petit peu partout tu vois tu as des
loges qu'on l'a ménages dont jill oda
est refusée puisqu'elle n'était pas
entièrement blanche
il a fallu repeint le voilà ça arrive
aussi pas une légende et est donc pas ce
que tu peux y arriver
sinon 34 alexora corps bloqués à nam
dinh nord badaboum crac crac total on se
retrouve avec plus personne sur scène et
pullicino qui réalisa me fait on est
dans la merde y'a personne sur scène des
boyaux quasiment tous les grands moments
je vous assure que c'est un moment de
solitude
tu sais plus c'était attendu c'est même
plus que tu racontes franchement moi
j'en ai un de vos qui est encore pire
l'école à bayeux avait remis en jeu
merci mais non il ya un moment où on
écoute et ce après midi et j'ai vraiment
pleuré dorée à l'or à la base c'est pas
drôle du tout mais dans le contexte
c'est extraordinaire c'était rtl et
laurent boyer appel pour la vallée rtl
la fameuse dans les artères et regardez
bien exécuté regardez bien ce qui se
passe il a way écoutez bien ce qui se
passe il a vraiment pris de chance
justement là allô bonjour madame
pourrais je parlais henry s'il vous
plaît oui bon j'ai dû faire néant je
suis passé henri mathurin à part dont
madame en bon dieu madame on est on est
tout à fait désolé c'était la valise rtl
et il y avait deux 1958 euros à gagner
[Musique]
elle a été montée
ça a été monté partie du bêtisier d'rtl
est ce que c'est un grand moment de
solitude
vous